>> EVERY MAN KNOWS HER NAME.
EVERY WOMAN KNOWS HER FACE.
WHEN SHE WALKS INTO A ROOM, ALL
EYES ARE ON HER.
SHE'S IVANKA.
♪♪♪
AND A WOMAN LIKE HER DESERVES A
FRAGRANCE ALL HER OWN.
A SCENT MADE JUST FOR HER.
BECAUSE SHE'S BEAUTIFUL.
SHE'S POWERFUL.
SHE'S -- COMPLICIT.
SHE'S A WOMAN WHO KNOWS WHAT SHE
WANTS.
AND KNOWS WHAT SHE'S DOING.
COMPLICIT.
SHE DOESN'T CRAVE THE SPOTLIGHT,
BUT WE SEE HER.
OH, HOW WE SEE HER.
COMPLICIT.
A FEMINIST, AN ADVOCATE, A
CHAMPION FOR WOMEN.
BUT, LIKE, HOW?
SHE'S LOYAL.
DEVOTED.
BUT PROBABLY SHOULD HAVE BOUNCED
AFTER THE WHOLE "ACCESS
HOLLYWOOD" BUS THING.
OH, WELL.
ALSO, I BET WHEN SHE WATCHES
"TITANIC," SHE THINKS SHE'S
ROSE.
SORRY, GIRL.
YOU'RE BILLY ZANE.
COMPLICIT, THE FRAGRANCE FOR THE
WOMAN WHO CAN STOP ALL THIS, BUT
WON'T.
ALSO AVAILABLE IN A COLOGNE FOR
JARED.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]